blue says matt i want you to know that
what you talked about towards the end of
the video right before the comment
section part you need to continue
hammering that point home as a 29 year
old single guy myself and with no family
and never had a father kind of sparked
something having a man i respect tell me
to go have an adventure and live in my
car if you are a young a young
able-bodied man and you have no
dependence and you have no one who's
relying on you
then the stakes are pretty low for you
and um
and you have a much better you have a
much greater ability to survive and
adapt than you realize and that is the
beautiful thing and if i can if i can
convince even one
guy to make one young man to make this
decision then i think it's a success you
can really go anywhere take advantage of
that go anywhere do anything just just
have an adventure it'll it'll be okay
you're gonna be making some sacrifices
you're not gonna be as comfortable but
it's exciting
go and build a life for yourself
be your own man